yes hello and welcome to this video this
is an something a little bit tricky to
say I've just just joined that hourly
super blitz arena on the chest this is a
three minute blitz tournament
the thing is I'm late I'm roughly that's
11 right 11 minutes late so it will be
tough to catch up with the leaders
you have got a game yeah I don't know if
I should preserve actually I mean I
should play quickly okay
no a case will immediately attack the
sentence is essentially gone filled with
the colors reversed should on these
seven words not really very
attractive-looking position for this oh
yeah maybe I'll stop him from castle
okay yeah do you want to take Galatea
and now try to try to open this as
quickly as possible
Bishop g5 now is a small threat if 6my
takes i think it's possible the rook is
hanging the whole time why am I not
taking the rook and would be it's a good
thing to ask I should just take the
bloody loop okay the vs start me not
taking this rook
okay so to kick that away
threatening g4 mate I mean maybe I can
accelerate things by going for a maid
okay that didn't work it's maybe a
little bit later group d4 d5 kingi 45
mate I need to win quickly so a little
bit of trickery could help but I can't
tell him prevent it anyway I mean oh
okay
so yeah behind a lot maybe I should
actually preserve okay I'm going to play
these three that was the most close a
f1e
yeah I like that this is certainly a
good position for Colin I've got a
pretty substantial space advantage
ob5 I should probably take and play with
c1 if he decides to play it
no b6 not sure what this is about
okay a different for something ahead on
the radar anyway open the position up
even more and it's called g5 like as I
you know I'm a space problem after night
move this f6 you know that's that's over
ready Queen g43 g7 checkmate he has to
take it on Essex this is also winning
more or less we're going win quickly
here only need to hook a 3x3
ninety-seven coming that's not not super
quick queen g6 Queen h4 we win the Queen
I don't have a maid though I wait he
could play okay Sam okay so that the
Zerg worked and then I'm kind of in the
hunt
not so far no so far back it's really
got five games on it that's crazy I need
to be paired quicker so it's a little
bit slow
now wait guys almost on moderating level
three minute is extremely clear anyway
so you can play slightly dubious lines
like this one no III this I have to play
almost anyway
okay much time and 95 what they were
doing that wasn't back it wasn't a good
move probably maybe it's not super
terrible as I can kick it back but it
wasn't a very successful thing to do one
little bit what what exactly did I do
wrong here I will say we should before
however that that cannot be good I mean
maybe not terrible but that's not really
asking anything special of my position
so maybe let's kick this I'm getting a
little bit more central control here
with this operation
Knight is very good only five and this
whole set FY looks really active Magnum
for Bishop d7 and stuff should be some
Ruby aid and stuff not very precise
I came yes he for his hanging but I
don't know probably not a wise idea
ah so he wants to make a draw now I
don't want to make it wrong 96 the way I
should have thought about this
and his whole Viet play is getting some
kind of justification okay okay
giving up this exchange right you for
now is the idea so not totally easy FEM
and bishops III I actually just taken
now probably should have just taken
it's not all that great don't go to
trade market chicken take c3 or here
still not check though this threatens
magic phone let's see
for Queen h5 maybe catch it here and go
for the pawn Knight g4 is a pretty big
threat it's good work for me I'm
actually been winning after f3 that's
made that's made that in tough game I
was probably probably lost them I mean
it's a point
okay so let's not a good position I
wanted to wanted to play fo of course
okay I'll take it
okay so I'm about to name a piece up
threatening on f5 and c6 now tickets
yeah and it's very good control just
text the h-bond I still have a minute on
the clock
I'd like to build some sort of meeting
it always makes it conquer right so form
fourth place and I'm just three points
behind so the level minutes have almost
more stone compensated but a big
difference right if you look at this
five to four games okay we might be
close to they're committing a game so it
is effectively morbid okay now blitz
rating is still it's not really highly
on that server I've seen that people
have like three thousand some some
people at least not sure how how good
this is at fault for Boozer King really
that's but the good thing about playing
your regular openings and those
situations is that you can
I sometimes play really quickly should
see 5s okay into it always hopeful
blunder
okay so 95 next is very much no more
okay let's get some space and Bishop f4
96 is now a threat at least I thought no
should win some stuff now that wins
apiece maybe even an exchange on top of
depends on what he does now it takes
that Bishop takes a leave me win the
rook but you will probably do something
else and he did should be six not yet
but we can threaten it
all right just very helpful I mean I'm
just trading but it is some so very okay
easy to play and I'm material up okay
I'll go back wasn't so great from a
technical point of view it should good
enough still it should have taken a
reform would have would have been a bit
a bit tougher just take this don't give
him any passes
moving quickly really come on
what slow 25 seconds should be very very
good okay so he resigned so second place
that way P is still ahead of me once
you're doing okay if like maybe he
resigns really I have a forgotten again
okay that's a way to get more games oops
but I'm happy here that's lots of
development for me to expect you to
Castle long okay this is also good you
should be h3 coming that should go I can
get in d5 that would be good let
acceptance a queen
now he's losing everything here okay so
the first place I did not intend to
preserve all games but there at the end
I cannot have - this is actually not
that bad
with the bishop one g5 the stone one has
a bit of an additional bite okay that's
aggressive but also extremely loose it's
something we me I would yeah I think I
just played this attend to quickly but
its buzzer King I wanted to open this up
as quickly as possible but that didn't
didn't quite work
not good name sure it is the same story
the moment I play something something
slightly wet I am getting into time
trouble and whatnot instead of playing
my usual stuff then especially it's true
for them the zerkin games em there's no
time I'd rather have something that I
know
and it was 795 I didn't make a single
little mistake yet this guy I think not
not a single mistake maybe I'm getting
somewhere now here was like this yeah I
don't know he has to probably cover
cover 86 you know that is a pretty
awkward pin is signal Queen to d6 just
nothing else I think
what else is there what else can there
possibly be Bishop c4 maybe you should
see six okay is everything mind us that
much look on the C file of course would
feel a lot better I should have checked
on e3 for so ending we've been easier I
think somehow I wanted to quite know how
which worked I am okay that's the other
guy
Oh mostly now mostly this wrong I played
it too quickly
v5i normally prevent with deform
I have a fairly normal position for the
English English opening reversed
reversed and dragon structure like it's
very solid too probably this position is
roughly equal b5 is very strange
I can almost sacrifice but this is of
course good
he just has weakened restructure
enormously and there is knowledge not a
clear compensation could have taken this
but this is also okay yes those
weaknesses I don't know maybe have some
idea against my bishop that I'm not
seeing would be sick so that's true
actually
Luke to be six as possible okay not too
happy with this but I have to
I know he has assured me to it I think
that miss places the bishop it's true is
going to be eight after that
unfortunately
miss quad rugby age and not did not see
this beforehand
unfortunately very very very badly
played structure-wise black was
completely busted like ten months ago
and then I got into this so it's bad
very superficially played
just just terrible in a vendor's keep
like b5 you know to kind of move after
which you just have to win there is no
bigger discussion there you just have to
win the game you just toast maybe not
actually destroy so it was terrible not
to win this game
after beside you just have to win yeah I
shouldn't have allowed to see five in
the first place it was not necessary to
do it okay so 16 minutes to go and can't
come on give me points points
okay at least you know that you can get
some early aggression in one piece and
I'm taking a piece to get to maybe look
here can take F to mating but then he
will probably let's take it I have a for
ID and
okay so drawback I could have taken c3
actually but maybe here it's better you
take here and Evon gimme gimme gimme
so default b5 is hanging but okay it's a
pin so I'm not threatening to take it
king jobs it's very generous pass me
more material we shouldn't get chick
mated Oh skip this back okay
not ideal probably paternity for next
there's some su mate don't see it can't
leave it and as I made yet for meet 13
left come on
need a couple of more games
yeah I need I need a game linear how
hips he's deserting okay and show me
what I could preserve myself but you can
just be be cool on the calf if you
answer be the quick the quick guy in
this game already some weird things
going on I could have taken on three
five actually one earlier that that also
cannot be all that terrible so that
should be pretty good player for the
exchange with the king sitting on D to
talk about it awkward pin and if I take
then that works
come on takes in Queen D for is close to
working and let also works
I get III end where I should have
dessert add D to do we have something
better than D to I probably not it looks
pretty good okay wait okay so we have
three left three and every left I'm
three behind that's what I want to say
but had a recent tournament where all of
a sudden from being three beer
fear ahead I was currently I was behind
a lot so I'm kind of skeptical it what
might have a snore and it's going for
its place something fine this is like
hate triply sharp line obviously and I
just kind of gambled a little bit in I
don't know this at all not at all Kayson
tink I can actually take when the night
that that threatens made on see to him
okay now and create fires also on here
Wow I shouldn't place this kind of stuff
and I'm just pawn down and have a bad
structure I'm not a pawn down actually
hmm anyway I should just view this as a
yeah as a windfall headed that I am NOT
a pawn down I was thinking of a ball now
but I'm not unexpected unexpected later
not a pawn down okay maybe I have some
kata here still not anything special
yeah looks such was fine this is also
fine probably yeah it's not nice to play
like this but I think I have to be
little bit conservative or government
cannot do anything fancy
I would like to reroute this and
relocate this I'm in the rook I need to
give my pawn up the right moment here's
the right moment okay so your g3o it
check
I want to trade this down and at the end
the end get to this and what's the idea
and just a lot more active it's it's
still wrong but maybe I have some
chances trying to get to the pawn so is
there a way to get to a seven without
ditching this in the first place and now
I can actually play work here cuts to
the draw but he's doing some things that
wait here h7 my king is not really well
positioned as the problem
the a takes is not quick enough
unfortunately yeah I have to try it I
mean you have to do you have to try
something okay
eight being the thread oh you should
have played with piayed no I'm just
promoting it for to a full queen I think
I always have to try yes was a little
something for a while okay but to app
has lost one so it seems that I'm going
to make it just seven seven points ahead
should be should be enough time to
celebrate the some mineral water can go
for one berserk at the end yeah this is
a very comfortable line for black nobody
has a we can structure and nothing
really to show for it
any traders helpful for me almost any
trade a queen eight five maybe it's
still threatened
because the three that Angus was checked
but okay it's not another nation I'm
sure I played that right I have to take
the buzzer King into a calendar bit it
will almost always be some kind of
superficial decision like you just
basically pre-move em medicines this is
good of course just pressing against the
pawns like this b6 Bishop f8 will be
tough for him to keep the material I
mean Seyfried in particular
look a five and then the other move to a
form that wins upon and the book on the
fifth is also covering f5 and stuff like
that so it's quite convenient oh let's
give that wins this one right you cannot
really cover the h-bomb at King can L
then I can help you cover cover this
stuff and a nose the moment to take g5
when you pawn after on
yeah g5 and then position is behind it's
a good way to do it technically quite
sound to labels
and g2 goes a bit more precise but so
quite simple
20 seconds for Queen f1 okay I don't
know did that count at the end I think I
had 40 before okay so I just had four
four points distance but yeah I'm happy
with the this I've started late and I
don't think I lost a game I think it
played something they won't draw any one
or two draws I don't know
yeah anyway I hope you enjoyed the video
thanks for watching